in a linear algebra course matrix
inverses are something that get a lot of
attention there are all these formulas
thrown at you like for the determinant
the inverse of two by two matrices
kram news rule etc etc these formulas
are great but I think that they can
obscure the very simple idea behind what
an inverse actually is and when it
exists you've probably been taught that
the inverse exists if and only if the
determinant isn't zero but most students
have no idea what the determinant has to
do with anything let alone inverses I'm
going to teach you a completely
different condition for when the inverse
exists that I think is much more
intuitive but before all that do you
know what a linear transformation is if
not go watch my last video because none
of this is going to make any sense at
all otherwise in fact if you want to
brush up on vectors and bases you can
watch the video before that too
even though this video is about matrix
inverses I'm not going to define what an
inverse is straight away instead I'm
going to define something called a left
inverse because I think understanding
these first will give you a better
intuition for inverses themselves
imagine you have a bunch of vectors in
some vector space in this case 2d and
you apply some matrix M on them here it
rotates them then you think you'd like
to have undone what you just did and get
the vectors back to where they were in
this example what transform undoes the
rotation you just rotate everything back
by the same angle right that's all a
left inverse is it's the matrix that
undoes the original matrix so it's like
you've done nothing at all if I wanted
to write this as an equation it would
say if you do M and then you do L it's
the same as if you did nothing this
thing is called the identity matrix by
the way and it just means the
transformation where you do nothing this
thing is called the left inverse for
hopefully obvious reasons so now we know
the left inverse is a matrix that undoes
the original matrixes action the
annoying thing about inverses is really
their name it sounds like the inverse
should be the thing that undoes a matrix
instead the definition of M inverse is M
inverse undoes M and M undoes M inverse
going back to our example if you do em
first and then L that's the identity but
it's also true that if you did L first
then M you'd also get the identity so
since L undoes M and is undone by M L
and M are inverses of each other
you might wonder is the left inverse
also always the inverse but obviously
not or they wouldn't have different
names would they before we move on let
me ask you a question to check you
understood this so far
imagine you have a matrix like this what
it does is it takes a 3d vector and then
jumbles up the components does this
matrix have a left inverse as in can you
undo this then if it does have a left
inverse figure out if it has an inverse
as well put your answer in the poll in
the corner and pause the video now to
think about it
[Music]
the answer is that it does have a left
inverse it's the one that takes a vector
like this and rearranges the components
like this it's clear that this is a left
inverse of a since it undoes it like so
[Music]
but a is also a left inverse of it as
you can see because a undoes this matrix
so B is the inverse of a now that we
know what an inverse is let's think more
about when they exist and don't again
it's going to be more convenient to look
at when a left inverse exists first
here's another question this matrix
takes a 2d vector a B and sends it to a
0 does this matrix have a left inverse
if so figure out what it is again put
your answer in the pole in the corner
and pause now to think about it notice
something about this matrix it takes the
vector a B to a 0 but it also takes ad
to a 0 as well this is a bad thing and
it's because of this that the left
inverse doesn't exist why well say you
have some vector V and M takes it to W
the left inverse of M if it exists knows
m and what W is but it doesn't know what
the vector that produced W was just
using the information given it needs to
find out what the original vector was so
that it can take W back to where it came
from however if there's some other
vector u that also goes to W the left
inverse has a problem it can't just look
at W and know for sure whether it came
from V or from you because there isn't
enough information
this means that the left inverse can't
take W back where it came from and so it
doesn't exist this thing here where two
different vectors V and u get mapped to
the same vector ie
mu equals MV is what I'll call em losing
information what we've just seen is that
if M loses information it doesn't have a
left inverse but what about the other
way around if M doesn't lose information
does this mean that the left inverse
exists well yes actually because all the
left inverse has to do to undo M is find
the vector W came from since there's
only one vector V could be there is an
inverse that takes the W and returns B
this doesn't mean it's easy to find out
what V is necessarily but looking at W
does in principle give you enough
information to undo M and returned V so
a matrix has a left inverse if and only
if it doesn't lose information
let's look at another example to
understand this point better imagine I
have a matrix from 2d to 3d and what it
does is it rotates any 2d vector into 3d
space like this does this matrix have a
left inverse pause the video to think
about it
[Music]
the answer is that it does have a left
inverse because a doesn't lose
information if you want to take vectors
like this back you know where they came
from so all you have to do is rotate
this plane back let B be a matrix that
takes 3d vectors to 2d that does rotate
this plane back it is a left inverse of
a now is B the inverse of a in other
words is a bees left inverse pause the
video and think about it
the answer is no B has no left inverse
we'll show that by showing the B loses
information first pick any 3d vector
that's on this plane B has to send it to
some 2d vector so let's just say it's
here
but there's another 3d vector that's
already been sent there it's this vector
u that's on the plane so bu is equal to
BV hence B loses information and doesn't
have a left inverse there's an important
lesson to be drawn from this example you
might have wondered why we only ever
talked about the inverses of square
matrices
[Music]
what's so special about transformations
from n dimensions to n dimensions the
reason is non square matrices ie ones
from n dimensions to M dimensions never
have an inverse the issue is if you have
any transformation going from a bigger
space to a smaller space like B which
went from 3d to 2d you have to lose
information these types of matrices
always send some vectors to the same
place
if you have a matrix from a smaller to a
bigger dimension it is possible for it
to have a left inverse like a did in our
example but it's left inverse goes from
big to small like B and so it can't be
undone hence even though some non square
matrices have left inverses they never
have an inverse square matrices don't
have these issues at all though actually
for square matrices everything massively
simplifies because the left inverse is
always equal to the inverse so if a
square matrix has a left inverse it
automatically has an inverse I'm not
gonna prove this fact you are for
homework but I will give you an
illustrative example in a little to help
you understand why it's true
once you've proved it you'll see that
for a square matrix a if B undoes a then
a undoes B as well this gives us an easy
criteria for checking whether a has an
inverse or not because it's the same
criteria we use to check whether a has a
left inverse just ask does a lose
information if yes then sorry a inverse
doesn't exist but if no then a inverse
does exist you might be thinking okay so
what how is this easy to check wouldn't
you have to compute the outcome of every
single vector that goes into M and then
compare the results to every other
vector and see if any of them match
isn't that beyond tedious thankfully
there is an easy way to check this
condition all you have to do is figure
out which vectors get mapped to zero for
any linear map 0 is always mapped to 0
but all you need to do is find out if
there are any other vectors mapped to 0
or not and that's enough to decide if M
loses information why would that be
enough imagine two vectors U and V both
go to W so M loses information then the
vector u minus B by linearity gets
mapped to 0 so whenever you have two
vectors going to the same thing like
this you always get at least two vectors
ending up at 0 so you can check whether
a matrix loses information by just
checking how many things go to 0 in
other words figure out how many vectors
B satisfy the equation MV equals 0 this
is part of why you spend so much time in
a linear algebra course studying the
solution of two equations like this
you can solve V by a using substitution
be using Gaussian elimination or C
getting your computer to do the Gaussian
elimination for you the point is you can
find out if M loses information easily
enough this way and that tells you
whether M has an inverse
let me summarize quickly what we learnt
in this video 1 a left inverse of a
matrix is a matrix that undoes it to
that the left inverse exists if you
don't lose information ie if the matrix
never sends two different vectors to the
same vector 3 the inverse is the matrix
that both undoes the matrix and is
undone by the matrix for non square
matrices never have inverses 5 for a
square matrix the left inverse is equal
to the inverse 6 you only need to check
if a square matrix loses information or
not to decide whether it has an inverse
and 7 you can check whether the matrix
loses information by looking at how many
different vectors get mapped to 0 this
you can do by solving the equation MV
equals 0 and so that's it but before you
run off kiss some homework for you the
first one is multiple choice which of
these is the inverse of this matrix I
know that you can just check each of
these to see which one works but I'd
rather you did it another way
and for crying out loud
don't use the formula for the inverse
[Music]
once you've figured it out put your
answer in the poll question to prove
that for a square matrix M inverse is
equal to the left inverse of M there's
lots of hints in the description for
this but first I want you to try
question 3 because it's a very
illustrative example suppose we have
this matrix from before if we have a
left inverse for at L then we know L
undoes M we also know that M takes the
basis vectors to these vectors so L must
take them back first show that these two
new vectors form a basis then to show
that M undoes L we need to show that for
any vector V if you apply L and then M
you get V back show this by writing V as
a linear combination of the basis in the
first part hopefully doing this will
help you with your proof in question 2
as you will have noticed the first
question is from brilliant org what I
like about questions from there is that
they don't just give you a formula and
then ask you questions where you plug
numbers into that formula that's what I
found a lot of high school and early
university textbooks do and it's
annoying because that doesn't teach you
anything
instead they get you to do examples like
this one and then understand the
principle yourself and then in the next
few questions lead you to finding the
general solution on your own
as you can see this is exactly how I
like to learn new maths before reading
the proof of anything I'll do lots and
lots of examples first and try and
understand the underlying reasoning so I
love how brilliant allows you to do this
in a structured way they have loads of
different maths and science courses on
their website which you can access
completely with a monthly or yearly
membership if you follow the link in the
description or on the screen you can get
20% off your annual subscription alright
so that's all for this video I hope you
enjoyed it the next one is about
changing basis which is key to
understanding loads of quantum mechanics
including the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle it should be up here in about
two weeks as long as I don't decide I
hate it just after uploading it like I
did with the original version of this
one anyway subscribe if you'd like to be
notified when the next one is up thanks
for watching